.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Vielleicht rettet Ihnen einer
dieser jungen Menschen mal das Leben.
Sie sind
angehende Pflegefachkräfte ...
... oder Rettungssanitäterinnen.
Die Ausbildung ist streng, der Beruf
spannend, aber anspruchsvoll.
Rebecca, Fanny ...
... Hélène und Lucas
wollen in einer Branche arbeiten,
die viele andere verlassen.
Warum - das erzählt diese Serie.
Es ist 7 Uhr morgens.
In Genf, im Spital Trois-Chêne,
macht sich Lucas
für seine Patientenrunde bereit.
Yamina schaut genau zu.
Du fragst, wenn etwas unklar ist.
Ja.
- Gehst du zu Frau Donche?
Ja. Zu Frau Donche,
Frau Saudan und Frau Weynette.
Bei den Vorbereitungen der Medi-
kamente darf kein Fehler passieren.
Ein falscher Griff
kann schlimme Folgen haben.
Da hat es viele Nullen.
- Wie viele?
Ich brauche 100'000.
Aber das sind 4'000 pro Milliliter.
100'000? Also, 100'000.
- Hast du 100'000er?
Ja, ich habe solche Packungen.
- Gut. Hier ist das Glas ja.
1 ml sind 20 Tropfen?
- Sehr gut.
Als Student muss ich immer
zuerst alles kontrollieren lassen,
bevor ich es den Patienten gebe.
Solange ich den Abschluss
noch nicht im Sack habe ...
... brauche ich das Okay
einer diplomierten Pflegefachperson.
Seine erste Patientin ist Nicole.
Sie wurde gestern Abend eingeliefert.
Frau Saudan?
Ich bringe Ihre Medikamente
für heute Morgen.
Ist gut.
- Ja?
Können Sie sich
an die Bettkante setzen?
Ich versuche es.
- Sonst helfe ich gerne.
Nicole stürzt ständig,
darum wollen die Ärzte rausfinden,
woran das liegen könnte.
Da haben wir Kalzium und Vitamin D.
Ist gut. Bestens.
- Das ist gut für die Knochen.
Sie können das zerbeissen.
Haben Sie Medizin studiert?
- Nein. Das nicht.
Ich mache die Ausbildung
zum Pflegefachmann.
Die Leute meinen oft, Lucas sei Arzt.
Es ist sehr typisch.
V.a.
die älteren Generationen denken,
wenn ein Mann ins Zimmer kommt,
sei das der Arzt.
Und eine Frau ist eine Pflegerin.
Ich muss manchmal lachen.
Aber gerade die Ärztinnen
finden das nicht so lustig.
Auf drei stehen Sie auf.
Eins, zwei und drei.
Sehr gut.
- Meine Güte.
Wunderbar.
- Noch ein bisschen.
So. Merci.
- Super.
Sie könnten nächstes Jahr
einen Marathon laufen.
Ich fand, man kam schnell
mit der Patientin in Kontakt.
Das ist natürlich toll.
Sie ist total selbstständig und un-
abhängig und kommt alleine zurecht.
Ich komme später noch mal vorbei.
- Mhm.
Geht es?
- Es muss.
Lucas, kommst du schnell?
- Komme.
Die Morgentour ist fertig
und Lucas bleibt Zeit zum Aufräumen.
Bei uns kommen alle dran, ob
Hilfspfleger oder Pflegefachkraft.
Unsere Räume müssen sauber sein.
- Klar.
Achtung.
- Jetzt ist das auch gemacht.
Lucas stellt sich
auf einen ruhigen Tag ein.
Cool. Heute ist alles ruhig.
Das darfst du nie sagen.
Du weisst nie,
was alles passieren kann.
Stimmt.
- Und Yamina hat recht.
Lucas' Patientin Nicole schläft tief
und will nicht aufwachen.
Etwas ist gar nicht gut.
Ich gebe Ihnen etwas Sauerstoff.
Nicoles Leben liegt in seinen Händen.
Aber Lucas hat noch nicht dieselben
Reflexe wie die erfahrene Yamina.
Wie tief war
die langsamste Herzfrequenz?- 38.
Auf 40.
Der Herzschlag der Patientin
wurde einfach immer langsamer.
Es war uns klar, dass etwas
schlecht und gefährlich war.
Lucas und Yamina
machen ein Notfall-EKG.
Nicoles Herz schlägt immer langsamer
und pausiert manchmal sogar.
Siehst du das?
- Ui. Es hat pausiert.
Da wird es langsamer. Ja. Da auch.
Hier wird es auch langsamer.
- Tatsächlich.
Dank des Sauerstoffs
kommt Nicole langsam wieder zu sich.
Frau Saudan,
bleiben Sie bitte wach.
Ihr Puls geht immer weiter runter.
Wir machen uns etwas Sorgen.
Machen Sie nichts Dummes, okay?
Mhm, abgemacht.
Das ist wahrscheinlich der Grund,
warum Sie so oft stürzen.- Klar.
Zum Glück
ist es im Spital passiert.
So sehen wir genau, was abläuft.
Ja.
- Und können Sie überwachen.
Nicoles Herz
kann jeden Moment stillstehen.
Der Arzt ist unterwegs.
Aber bis er da ist, müssen die
Pflegefachleute reagieren können,
wenn die Patientin
reanimiert werden muss.
Ich hole die Vene hervor.
- Machen Sie nur.
Ich würde einen grünen nehmen.
- Warum?
Dann hat sie einen grösseren Zugang.
Falls wir sie reanimieren müssen.
- Klar.
Grüne Venenkatheter
haben einen grösseren Durchmesser
und lassen die Medikamente
schneller durch.
Aber es ist schwieriger,
so einen Katheter zu legen.
Gerade bei älteren Leuten, bei denen
man die Venen manchmal kaum sieht.
Lucas macht es heute zum ersten Mal.
- Ich habe fast etwas Angst.
Ich mache den Einstich.
- Ja.
Reicht das so?
- Sieht gut aus.
Tipptopp.
Dieses Mal gelang es ihm auf Anhieb.
Voilà.
Er machte das wie ein alter Hase.
Sehr versiert.
Schon vorbei.
- Merci.
Nicole kann verlegt werden.
Aber zuerst wollen die Ärzte wissen,
ob sie bei einem Herzstillstand
reanimiert werden möchte.
(Arzt) Ich habe eine wichtige Frage:
Sollte Ihr Herz stehen bleiben,
sollen wir versuchen,
Sie zu reanimieren?
Was ist Ihre Meinung dazu?
Bevor meine Katze nicht tot ist,
sterbe ich auch nicht.
Das sahen wir nicht kommen.
Dass sie sagt:
"Ich will so lange leben
wie meine Katze."
"Ich will erst sterben,
wenn sie gegangen ist."
Das habe ich noch nie gehört.
Das ist sehr speziell.
Aber für die Dame machte das Sinn.
Sie sagte mir auch, ihre Kinder
und Enkel seien erwachsen.
Die bräuchten sie nicht mehr.
Sprechen wir mal nur von Ihnen.
Ihre Katze lassen wir
für einen Moment auf der Seite.
Was sagen Sie dann?
- Warum auf der Seite?
Es kann sich jemand anderes
um sie kümmern.
Meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen
möchten wissen,
ob es für Sie stimmt,
dass wir versuchen,
Ihr Herz wieder in Gang zu bringen.
Äh ...
Ich bin überfragt.
- Alles klar.
Solang Nicole
keine klare Antwort geben kann,
würde man sie
auf jeden Fall reanimieren.
Sie wird jetzt
auf die Überwachungsstation verlegt.
(Frau)
Ich sage es. Salut, ich bin's.
Wir schicken dir eine Patientin.
Lucas, der Praktikant, ist dabei.
So eine Verlegung
ist eine grosse Herausforderung.
Ich kümmere mich um Frau Saudan
und du machst das Dossier.
Du machst dann die Übergabe.
Ist gut, ich mache das.
(Frau) Wo sind die Kleider?
- In der roten Tasche.
Frau Saudan,
wir bringen Sie nach oben.
Eine Uhr ist auch noch da.
- In eine andere Abteilung.
Wir dürfen sie
nicht ohne Überwachung raufschicken.
Es muss immer ein Arzt mit.
Bei einem so tiefen Herzschlag
kann jederzeit ...
... ein Stillstand passieren.
Im Lift oder im Gang.
Geht es, Frau Saudan?
Ruft jemand den Lift? So.
Keine Angst. Es kommt gut.
Achtung. Achtung.
Der Transport dauert nur ein paar
Minuten, aber es kann viel passieren.
Es rüttelt etwas, tut mir leid.
Lucas stellt die Patientin vor.
- Ja.
Er ist im letzten Ausbildungsjahr
an der Hochschule für Gesundheit.
Nicole ist unversehrt angekommen
und Lucas übergibt sie den Kollegen.
Frau Saudan, Nicole,
12. August 1935.
Seit gestern bei uns
wegen mehrfacher Stürze.
Kein Schädeltrauma,
keine Ohnmacht, keine Anästhesie.
Es ist Lucas'
erster richtiger Notfall.
Grutblinnungs...
- Wir haben Zeit.
Nur nicht zu schnell.
- ... Blutgerinnungshemmer.
Ich bin froh.
- Also, Frau Saudan:
Passen Sie auf sich auf.
Es kommt von Herzen, aber
"Auf Wiedersehen" sage ich nicht.
Achten Sie auf sich.
- Merci, Sie auch.
In Lausanne
kümmert sich Hélène um Sylvette,
die heute operiert werden soll.
Madame Golay?
Ist das richtig ausgesprochen?
Ja.
Perfekt. Ich bin Hélène Fontaine.
Ich arbeite seit zwei Monaten
hier als Praktikantin.
Ich begleite Sie heute.
Es ist ein kleiner Eingriff,
der bevorsteht.
Aber Sylvette hat grosse Angst.
Das geht schon. Wir haben Zeit,
um alles in Ruhe zu besprechen.
Ich zeige Ihnen Ihr Zimmer ...
- Der Anästhesist sagte,
Sie würden mir ein Temesta
zur Beruhigung geben.
Ja.
Sylvette
braucht sofort ein Beruhigungsmittel.
Ich kriege Platzangst, wenn man mich
auf den Operationstisch legt.
Sie sagte, sie sei sehr gestresst
wegen der Operation.
Und sie habe Platzangst.
Bevor wir überhaupt im Lift standen.
Sie hoffe, es sei schnell durch.
Bitte. Im Lift geht es?
- Ja. Der Lift ist kein Problem.
Okay. Bestens.
Sylvette hat die Operation
lange rausgeschoben.
Hier geht es durch.
Stresst Sie die Operation
oder die Klaustrophobie mehr?
Beides.
Man hätte den Eingriff ambulant
mit Lokalnarkose machen können,
aber ich wollte eine Vollnarkose.
Ich kann keine Spritzen sehen.
Ich habe seit Wochen
Albträume wegen des Eingriffs.
Das stärkste Beruhigungsmittel
hilft da nicht.
Dazu kommt eine Panik,
wenn ich mich nicht bewegen kann.
Darum möchte ich während der OP
schlafen.- Verstehe ich.
Sylvette muss
ihre Krampfadern entfernen lassen.
Noch der Blutdruck.
Es ist normal, dass Sie so kurz
vor der Operation nervös sind.
Ich war Coiffeuse.
Ich hatte keine Krampfadern
in all den Jahren.
Als ich pensioniert wurde,
kriegte ich Probleme mit den Beinen.
Anfangs hatte ich Krämpfe,
und dann kamen die Krampfadern.
Dann hat es ...
Das juckte,
und dann fing es an wehzutun.
Hélène fragt die Patientin,
woher sie komme,
und kann sie so etwas ablenken.
Die Aussicht ist herrlich.
Man sieht auf den Lac des Brenets
und den Lac de Joux.
Dr. Lüthi wartet schon auf Sylvette.
- Grüezi.- Grüezi.
Wie geht es?
- Ja, es geht.
Prima.
Ich schaue, ob meine Zeichen auf
den Beinen nicht verschwunden sind.
Ich habe aufgepasst.
Nicht, dass Sie schimpfen.
Es sieht sehr gut aus.
Hélène ist zum ersten Mal
im Operationssaal.
Zuerst kommt der Narkosearzt.
(Anästhesist)
Das ist quasi der Aperitif.
Nur nicht so lecker.
- Ja ...
Heute kann sie
bei der Operation dabei sein.
Das gehört zur Ausbildung
und ist eine einmalige Gelegenheit,
die sie nicht mehr
so schnell haben wird.
Jetzt schlafen Sie gleich.
Sylvette schläft jetzt tief.
Und Hélène erhält eine kleine
Privatlektion in Chirurgie.
Hélène,
sehen Sie gut auf den Bildschirm?
Ja.
- Jetzt sieht man ...
... wie das Plastikteil
in die Vene eindringt.
Dadurch können wir
den Katheter einführen.
Können Sie mir den Katheter geben?
Merci.
Der Katheter hat ein Teil,
das heiss wird.
Das hier.
- Okay.
Der Arzt verödet jetzt
die Venen von innen her.
Nach dem Eingriff hat Sylvette wieder
schöne und v.a. schmerzfreie Beine.
Ist das die Vene?
- Und der weisse Punkt der Katheter.
Und das Ende
ist die Spitze des Katheters.
Es ist super,
wenn ein Arzt so offen ist.
Er beantwortet auch Fragen und
nimmt sich Zeit für den Patienten
und für alle,
die bei der Operation dabei sind.
So wissen alle, was er macht -
von der Pflege bis zum Spezialisten.
Jetzt können wir ...
... ein Stück der Vene
ganz langsam hier rausziehen.
Voilà.
50 Min. Operation.
Allen vielen Dank.
- (Frau) Gleichfalls.
Und ein paar Zentimeter Venen
weniger.
Die trocknet jetzt langsam.
Das ist mir neu.
- Was?
Ich wusste nicht, dass man
ein Stück Vene rausnehmen kann.
Wir Ärzte
haben auch eine Lehrfunktion.
Es gehört dazu, dass man anderen
zeigt, wie man so etwas macht.
Ja, das ist gut.
(Anästhesist) Frau Saudan,
es ist alles gut gegangen.
Ich gebe Ihnen Sauerstoff,
und dann geht es zurück ins Bett.
* Gemütliche Musik *
Es sind noch keine 24 Std. vergangen.
Schönen guten Morgen.
- Grüezi.
Wie geht es Ihnen?
- Mir ist etwas schwindlig.
Etwas schwindlig?- So tief
habe ich noch nie geschlafen.
Meine Schnorre ist ganz trocken.
- Ihre Schnorre?
So heisst das halt.
Sylvette ist wieder die Alte.
Ich spüre nichts.
Im OP ging alles so schnell,
dass Sie nichts merkten.
Sie sagen es.
Ich war total entspannt.
Ich kann mich an nichts erinnern.
Sylvette ist die letzte Patientin,
die Hélène
als Praktikantin betreut hat.
Jetzt muss sie sich
auf die Abschlussprüfung vorbereiten.
Machen Sie es gut.
- Auf Wiedersehen.- Da bist du.
Ade.
(Frau) Das ist die 142.
Wir sind wieder im Geriatriespital
Trois-Chêne in Genf.
Nach zwei Wochen
geht es Nicole deutlich besser.
Sehr gut.
Jetzt ganz langsam hinsetzen.
So.
- Das klappt ja bestens. Toll.
Das ist ein Aufsteller.
Das hört man gerne.
Gerade bei uns im Notfall
kriegen wir selten mit,
wie es den Leuten geht,
die wir betreut haben.
Und wieder hinsetzen.
Gerade bei Frau Saudan
machten wir uns Sorgen.
Es ging ihr sehr schlecht,
als sie zu uns kam.
Schön den Fuss nachziehen.
- Good news tun einem immer gut.
Das stellt einen auf.
Gut abstützen in der Kurve.
Der Grund für Nicole Saudans schlech-
ten Zustand war ein Medikament,
das den Herzrhythmus verlangsamte.
Jetzt freut sie sich auf ihr Zuhause
und ihre Katze.
Ich gebe mir alle Mühe. Sehen Sie?
Mein Gott.
Ich hoffe,
dass ich früher nach Hause kann.
Darum mache ich alles,
was sie wollen.
Bist du so weit?
- Yes.
Yamina bewertet Lucas' Praktikum.
Es waren drei strenge Monate.
In dieser Zeit
entstand zwischen Lucas
und der erfahrenen Pflegefachfrau
Yamina eine Vertrautheit.
Du hast es geschafft.
Zeit, um "Ade" zu sagen.
Oder wer weiss,
vielleicht "Auf Wiedersehen".
Gib mir Bescheid, wie es weitergeht.
- Klar.
Wir hatten dich jedenfalls
gerne im Team.
Alle schätzten deine Art,
auch die Ärzte.
Mir gefiel v.a., wie du dich
in Patienten einfühlen kannst.
Und du achtest immer darauf,
auf Augenhöhe mit ihnen zu reden.
Physisch?
- Genau.
Das fand ich total gut.
Das ist echt wichtig.
Mir ist wichtig, einen positiven
Eindruck zu hinterlassen.
Das hast du.
- Gut.
Viel Erfolg. Behalte dein Lächeln
und deinen Optimismus.
Bleib so offen und einfühlsam
gegenüber den Leuten.
So, wie ich dich kennenlernte.
Das ist extrem wichtig.
Das ist das Wichtigste
für eine Pflegefachperson:
die Pflege der zwischenmenschlichen
Beziehungen.- Ja.
Jedenfalls alles Gute
für deinen weiteren Weg.
Danke.
Und man weiss nie ...
- Nein.
Falls ich in ein paar Jahren
noch hier bin.
Ah ja. Das wäre auch unterschrieben.
Ja ... Er ist bereit zum Arbeiten.
Ja.
Machst du deine Abschiedsrunde?
- Genau.
Ich sage "Tschüss".
Vielleicht treffen wir uns wieder.
Das ist gut möglich.
- Ja.
Die Welt ist kleiner, als man denkt.
- Auf jeden Fall.
Danke euch allen. Bis bald.
- (Alle) Tschüss, Lucas.
Am liebsten
würde ich wieder umdrehen.
Irgendwann
muss man loslassen können.- Klar.
Es ist keine einfache Trennung.
Also: tschüss.
Schau mal.
* Lachen *
Komm, Lucas. Du darfst weinen.
- Tschau, Lucas.
Tschau, Lucas.
Es ist wirklich komisch.
Plötzlich wird einem bewusst,
wie schnell die Zeit vergeht.
Das Studium ist bald fertig.
Eigentlich kann ich es kaum erwar-
ten, endlich richtig zu arbeiten.
Zuerst kommt aber noch
die Abschlussprüfung.
Fanny hat die Prüfung
schon hinter sich.
Hello.
Sie ist inzwischen
diplomierte Rettungssanitäterin.
Und arbeitet auch an Heiligabend.
Während die Leute in Payerne
den Christbaum schmücken,
beginnt Fanny ihren Nachtdienst.
Heute arbeitet sie mit Carine,
die schon seit vielen Jahren
bei der 144 ist.
Die beiden Rettungssanitäterinnen
sind bereit für alles.
Und damit
etwas Feststimmung aufkommt,
gibt es heute ein Fondue chinoise.
Du kannst sonst Salat essen.
- So weit kommt es noch.
Was brauchen wir noch?
Wir haben alles.- Nichts mehr.
Wir stossen mit Wasser an.
- Aber sicher.
Es macht Spass, zusammen zu essen.
Aber sonst ist es eine Nacht
wie jede andere auch.
Guten Appetit.
- Guten Appetit.
Schöne Weihnachten.
- Ja.
Wir müssen angeben,
wann wir arbeiten wollen:
an Weihnachten oder Neujahr.
Die Planung
berücksichtigt die Präferenz.
Aber man muss an einem
der beiden Festtage arbeiten.
Der Frieden währt nicht lange.
Den ersten Einsatz haben die
Rettungssanitäterinnen in Moudon,
wo eine ältere Frau gestürzt ist.
Ihr Mann hat gerade angerufen.
Wie alt ist sie? 67?
- Nein, 80.
80. Mal schauen.
Das erste Problem
ist die extrem enge Einfahrt.
Das wird knapp.
Wie sieht es bei dir aus?
Ja.
- Gut.
Wie sie wieder rauskommen,
schauen sie später.
Guten Abend.
- Im hinteren Zimmer.
Sind Sie gestürzt?
- Nein, meine Frau.
Ich gehe zu ihr. Salut, Hündchen.
(Frau) Guten Abend.
- Was ist passiert?
Darf ich mich vorbeidrücken?
- Sind Sie gestürzt?
Wir stützen Ihren Kopf,
damit wir alles untersuchen können.
Ja.
- Wissen Sie, wer Sie sind?
Ja, klar.
- Wissen Sie, wo Sie sind?
Ja, wir sind in ...
Ja, wo sind wir?
- Im Spital in Payerne.
Okay, Sie sind im Spital in Payerne.
Öffnen Sie bitte die Augen.
Wo sind Sie hier?
- In Payerne.
Ist das Payerne?
- Ich denke.
Alles klar. Okay.
Sie sind noch zu Hause.
Ja.
- Okay.
Öffnen Sie bitte die Augen.
Wie heissen Sie mit Vornamen?
Jeanine.
- Jeanine?
Ich spreche Sie mit dem Vornamen an,
okay?- Ja.
Ich kontrolliere Ihr Genick.
Schmerzt das?- Nein.
Nein.
Und hier?
- Nein, ich glaube nicht.
Wo ist das Licht?
- Da.
Sehr gut, schauen Sie ins Licht.
Öffnen Sie die Augen.
Pupillen erweitert?
- Ja.
Reagieren sie?
- Ich leuchte nicht voll rein.
Normale Grösse,
aber nicht sehr reaktiv.
Darf ich Sie etwas fragen?
Haben Sie es gehört,
als sie stürzte?
(Mann) Sie wollte zur Toilette.
- Kam Sie Ihnen normal vor?
Nein.
- Ist sie jetzt wie immer?
Nein, völlig neben den Schuhen.
- Neben den Schuhen?- Komplett.
Während Carine
mit dem Ehemann spricht,
misst Fanny den Blutzuckerspiegel.
Ich steche Ihnen in den Finger.
- Ja.
Sie waren nicht ohnmächtig, oder?
- Nein.
Was ist passiert?
- Ja, Blutzucker 8,4.
Jeanine wollte zur Toilette
und stürzte plötzlich.
In ihrem Zustand muss sie ins Spital.
Aber sie muss doch noch zur Toilette.
Halten Sie sich an mir fest,
Jeanine.
Wunderbar. Sehr gut.
- Ich habe Sie.
Schritt für Schritt.
- Stützen Sie mich?
Ja, ja.
- Kommen Sie. Super.
Das Entscheidende in unserem Beruf
ist die Anpassung an den Patienten.
Man muss langsam
und sehr deutlich sprechen,
sich viel wiederholen
und einfache Wörter brauchen.
Dann geht es schon.
Haben Sie eine Jacke oder so?
- Voilà.
Genau so. Noch etwas drehen
und einen Schritt zurück.
Da ist der Stuhl. Und hinsetzen.
- Einfach hinsetzen.
Jeanine ist verwirrt.
Als ihr Mann sich verabschieden will,
erkennt sie ihn nicht mehr.
Er soll näherkommen.
- Wer ist das?
Ist sie schon länger so apathisch?
- Nicht so stark.
Ich ziehe sie rein.
Jetzt haben
die beiden Rettungssanitäterinnen
aber noch ein anderes Problem.
- Können wir umdrehen?
Nein.
- Dann halt rückwärts.
Es war Nacht und die Autokameras
sind nicht die besten.
* Spannende Musik *
Nicht gut.
Gut.
Wenn es 10 Min. dauert,
dauert es halt 10 Min.
Besser das,
als den Rettungswagen kaputtmachen.
Sonst dauert es noch länger.
Alles gut.
Geht es Ihnen besser?
- Es geht so.
Wo sind wir? Wo sind wir hier?
Im Spital in Payerne.
- Wir sind im Krankenwagen.
Salut, Carine von
der Rettungssanität. Geht es gut?
Wir fahren jetzt in Moudon ab
und sind in 15 Min. bei euch.
Die Patientin
hat Verständnisstörungen ...
Carine gibt alle Informationen
an die Notfallaufnahme
des Spitals Payerne durch.
Im Spital übergeben
die zwei Rettungssanitäterinnen
die Patientin
dem Bereitschaftsdienst.
So.
Jetzt können wir
den Sicherheitsgurt öffnen.
Drei.
Meine Kollegen machen jetzt weiter.
Alles Gute.- Alles Gute. Ade.
Gleichfalls.
Carine und Fanny
haben ihre Aufgabe erfüllt.
Warte.
Was mir an dem Beruf gefällt:
Er ist vielfältig.
Und es hat viele technische Dinge.
Da muss man viel nachdenken.
Und nach der Behandlung
fährt man noch die Ambulanz.
Das mache ich sehr gerne.
Man muss sich technisch
in anderen Feldern auskennen.
Das gefällt mir gut.
Jetzt geht es zurück in die Zentrale,
wo bald der nächste Einsatz
auf die beiden wartet.
Rebecca hat ihre Abschlussprüfung
glänzend bestanden
und hat eine Stelle in der Abteilung
für Viszeralchirurgie
im Universitätsspital Genf erhalten.
Dort, wo sie schon
ihr Praktikum gemacht hat.
Heute ist ihr erster Arbeitstag.
Kommt ihr alle aus derselben Klasse?
- (Alle) Ja.
Ich habe es
noch nicht ganz realisiert.
Heute Morgen
hatte ich immer noch das Gefühl,
ich käme für das Praktikum hierher.
Beim offiziellen Empfang
kam ich mir vor wie in der Schule.
Ich verstehe echt noch nicht,
dass ich hier arbeite.
Wir geben euch einen Überblick
über die Abteilungen.
Die verantwortlichen Pflegefachfrauen
der Chirurgie
stellen den Neuankömmlingen
ihre Abteilung vor.
Damit ihr besser versteht,
was um euch herum passiert.
Jeden Monat kommen
mehrere Dutzend Pflegefachkräfte
neu ins Genfer Unispital arbeiten.
In einer Struktur
mit rund 13'000 Mitarbeitenden
ist so ein Empfangsmorgen
reine Routine.
(Film) Die Türen der Abteilung
für Chirurgie stehen nun offen.
Ihr könnt es sicher kaum erwarten.
Ich möchte am liebsten anfangen.
Darum bin ich ja hier.
Aber eine gewisse Angst
ist natürlich auch da.
Ich bin jetzt Pflegefachfrau.
Es schützt mich niemand mehr.
Ich trage die Verantwortung.
Ich kann auf niemanden zählen.
Ausser auf mich selber. Das ist neu.
Herzlich willkommen.
- Herzlich willkommen.
Voilà. Willkommen.
Um 14 Uhr nachmittags
hat Rebecca ihre erste
Übergabesitzung als Pflegefachfrau.
Ich darf Ihnen
zwei neue Kollegen vorstellen.
Sie fangen am Montag bei uns an.
Das sind Flavio und Rebecca,
die ihr schon kennt.
Herzlich willkommen. Guten Start.
- Ich bin total stolz.
Als ich meinen Badge holte,
und nicht mehr "Lernende",
sondern "Pflegefachfrau" draufstand,
drehte ich fast durch.
Echt bombastisch.
Dort kapierte ich es wirklich.
Ich stehe hier.
Ich habe es geschafft. Endlich. Ja.
(Frau) Hast du die Mail mit der
Medikamentenliste schon geschickt?
Hélène hat Emilie und Célia zu
ihren Eltern nach Hause eingeladen,
die in Morges wohnen.
- Ihr habt wohl viel zu tun.
Nach dem Brunch besprechen
die drei Freundinnen ein Projekt,
das sie nach der Abschlussprüfung
verwirklichen wollen.
Sie wollen
nicht sofort eine Stelle suchen,
sondern zuerst etwas unternehmen,
das sie schon lange wollten.
Die haben für uns
schon eine Packliste gemacht.
Ich habe auch schon
einiges aufgeschrieben.
Sie wollen in Afrika
humanitäre Hilfe leisten.
Wir brauchen
ein Koskite... Moskitne...
Das fängt ja schon gut an.
- Muskite...
Wir müssen fragen, ob wir die
Uniformen mitnehmen sollen.- Gut.
Das Ziel der Reise ist Tansania.
Es scheint zwar alles noch weit weg,
aber die Hilfsorganisation vor Ort
hat schon
einen Einsatzplan geschickt.
Wir haben die Reise
schon ewig im Kopf.
Schon seit dem Anfang.
- Ja.
Wir tranken da mal was zusammen
und diskutierten das.
Hat es keine Fotos? Nur Karten?
Ein Foto des Kilimandscharo.
Wir schliessen uns einer Organisa-
tion mit Fokus auf Gesundheit an.
Wir reisen aber auch.
Wir gehen z.B. zu den Massai.
Drei Tage lang.
Wir haben genug Ideen.
Wir werden sicher
viel über uns selber lernen.
Und über unsere Gewohnheiten
und Werte.
Wir müssen demütig bleiben. Also,
nicht den grossen Retter spielen,
nur weil wir aus einem viel rei-
cheren und moderneren Land kommen.
Wir müssen bescheiden bleiben.
Dort macht man viel anders,
mit einfacheren Mitteln.
D.h. aber nicht, dass wir
alles besser wissen oder machen.
Es braucht viel Vorbereitung
für eine solche Reise.
Und auch Mut.
- Ah, eine Heuschrecke.
* Lachen *
Ruhig bleiben, Célia.
- Wenn du schon davor Angst hast ...
Hast du Angst?
So kannst du nicht nach Tansania.
Ein fieses Monster.
Unispital Genf.
Rebecca bereitet sich auf ihren Tag
in der Viszeralchirurgie vor.
Es ist bald 7 Uhr morgens.
Seit drei Wochen
arbeitet sie als Pflegefachfrau
und kümmert sich alleine
um mehrere Patienten.
Die Kolleginnen der Nachtschicht
geben jetzt die Informationen weiter.
Er will mit dem Arzt sprechen.
Er heisst Étienne und ist 42.
Er sollte gestern nach Hause,
aber der Magendarmspezialist sagte,
er habe ein Geschwür.
So steht es im Rapport.
Das könnte bluten.
Er geht erst nach Hause,
wenn der Befund der Biopsie da ist.
Der neue Patient,
der auf Rebecca wartet,
hat eine Autismusspektrumstörung.
Darum verunsichert ihn
jede Veränderung.
Ich weiss,
dass Personen mit Autismus ...
... in einem Moment
komplett ängstlich sein können.
Aber dann trotzdem aufgeschlossen.
Aber auch fadengerade
alles ohne Filter sagen.
Er habe schlecht geschlafen
wegen der Schmerzen.
Okay.
- Die würden ihn immer plagen.
Julien kam mit starken Bauchschmerzen
in den Notfall.
Man weiss nicht, woher sie kommen.
Er ist sehr lichtempfindlich
und trägt darum eine dunkle Brille.
Hatten Sie heute Morgen Schmerzen?
- Ja, hier drüben. Enorme.
Dieselben wie gestern?
- Ja, wie gestern.
Es tut stark weh,
aber ich weiss nicht warum.
Okay.
Ich gehöre ganz dir.
- Wunderbar.
Julien duzt Rebecca.
Aber als Pflegefachfrau
muss sie die Regeln einhalten
und ihre Patienten siezen.
Sie haben
eine etwas erhöhte Temperatur.
Habe ich eine erhöhte Temperatur?
- Ja. 38,2 °C.
Julien vertraut Rebecca
und erzählt ihr,
was ihn am Abend vorher störte.
Ja?
Es gab ein Missverständnis zwischen
den verantwortlichen Diensten.- Ja.
Ja.
- Was ist passiert?
Der Krankenwagen
brauchte eine Ewigkeit.
Okay.
Darüber zu sprechen,
was nicht funktioniert hat
und Verständnis zu zeigen,
hilft dabei, jemanden zu beruhigen.
Durch Zuhören
kann ich am meisten helfen.
Als Autist
ist man einfach empfindlich.
Ich kann nichts dafür.
- Empfindlich sein ist okay.
Die Leute
machen manchmal Dinge, die ...
Ja,
die man halt noch nie gemacht hat.
Rebecca versteht, dass Julien
sich über die Ärzte aufregt.
Sie versprachen ihm
Untersuchungsergebnisse,
die noch nicht gekommen sind.
- Ich habe keine Kontrolle mehr.
Seit ich im System Spital bin,
bestimme ich über nichts.
So, das haben wir.
Ich hole noch eine Flasche Wasser.
- Packst du sie mir aus?
Die Tabletten? Mache ich.
Julien hat schon viele Erfahrungen
mit Spitälern gemacht.
Die lege ich hierhin und die hier.
Ich kenne
das eine oder andere Spital.
Ich war
schon als Baby häufig Patient.
Schon als kleiner Junge begriff ich,
welche Schlüsselrolle
eine Krankenpflegerin hat.
Man sieht sofort,
wer die Menschen mag
und die Arbeit
aus Nächstenliebe macht.
Dann gibt es auch richtige Hexen.
Das kann man nicht anders sagen.
So.
Mit Rebecca stimmte es sofort.
Sie ist die einzige Person,
die nie Druck auf mich ausübt
und nicht über mich urteilt.
Rebecca versucht,
möglichst auf jeden Wunsch
ihrer Patienten einzugehen.
Julien weiss das zu schätzen
und sagt das auch.
So,
das Rivotril und das frische Wasser.
Du Schatz.
Sollte ich je in den Himmel kommen,
will ich nur Engel wie dich um mich.
Das ist sehr nett.
Er ist eine Person,
die sehr fair ...
... aber lustig und aufgestellt ist.
Aber er
ist voller Sorgen und Ängste.
Er sagt alles so, wie es ist,
ohne Filter.
Rebecca muss sich beeilen,
wenn sie all ihre Patienten sehen
will, bevor die Arztvisite beginnt.
Haben Sie Schmerzen an der Hand?
- Nein.
Vor ein paar Tagen
war die Abteilung voll.
Wir sind nur drei Pflegefachleute.
Ich ass nichts, machte keine Pausen
und ging nicht zur Toilette.
Vor der Visite will der Arzt
alles genau mit Rebecca durchgehen.
Morgen machen wir
ein paar Untersuchungen.
Er ist ziemlich aufgewühlt.
- Warum?
Weil die von der Gastro
ihm gesagt haben,
es sei eine Zyste,
die stark bluten könnte.
Er hat Angst, dass wir ihn
zu früh nach Hause schicken.
Okay.
Der Arzt hat Verständnis
und Julien muss sowieso noch bleiben.
Wir müssen
noch ein paar Dinge abklären.
Es ist keine Zyste,
aber wir behalten ihn bei uns.
Wir haben ja keine Diagnose.
- Es liegt immer noch kein Befund vor
und der Arzt
kann Julien nichts sagen,
obwohl er weiss,
wie sehr er auf eine Antwort wartet.
Er hat mir versprochen,
dass er die Sache beschleunigt.
Und dass ich heute eine Diagnose
mit Therapievorschlägen kriege.
Also, es ist noch nicht klar,
wann der Befund eintrifft.
Wenn alles normal läuft
heute oder morgen.
Ich hoffe, noch heute.
Er sagte, ich sollte heute abgeholt
werden, um einkaufen zu gehen.
Meine Logistik zu Hause
ist nämlich sehr komplex.- Ja.
Das beunruhigt mich stark.
Seit ich hier bin,
kriege ich nur unklare Antworten.
Das ist, weil die Untersuchung
noch nicht abgeschlossen ist.- Ja.
Wann kann ich nach Hause?
Das kann ich
erst am Nachmittag sagen.- Gut.
Tipptopp.
- Ich habe Glück im Unglück.
Denn ich habe Rebecca.
Das ist ein grosses Glück.
Der Arzt
muss zu den anderen Patienten.
Aber Rebecca
hat Julien nicht vergessen.
Ich habe mit Ihrer Betreuungsperson
telefoniert.
Ich sah,
dass er über etwas sprechen möchte.
Und zwar über ein Problem.
Darum ging ich zu ihm
und sprach das an.
Das ist wichtig
bei Leuten mit Autismus.
Ich habe ihr gesagt,
Sie würden sich Sorgen machen.
Danke für alles.
- Aber gerne.
Es ist Abend und
die Nachtschicht übernimmt wieder.
Juliens Befund
ist aber immer noch nicht da.
Rebecca informiert ihre Kollegin
über alles, was passiert ist.
Er ist total im Stress, weil er
nicht weiss, wann er entlassen wird.
Aber das kann man erst sagen,
wenn der Befund der Biopsie da ist.
Der sollte wirklich langsam kommen.
Das war es.
Vor dem Heimgehen
sagt sie ihren Patienten gute Nacht.
Sind Sie wach?
Ich wollte mich nur verabschieden.
Ich überlasse Sie meinen Kollegen.
Dann halt. Mhm.
- Gut? Also.
Einen schönen Abend.
- Merci.
Alles Gute.
- Gleichfalls.
Morgen bin ich wieder hier.
Aber ich hoffe,
Sie können dann schon nach Hause.
Man muss ihn nehmen, wie er ist
und ein bisschen mit ihm lachen.
Im Wesentlichen
blieb ich einfach mich selbst.
Jetzt muss sich Rebecca beeilen.
Am Abend treffen sich alle angehenden
Pflegefachleute des Kantons Genf
zur Diplomübergabe.
Es ist das Ende
der dreijährigen Ausbildung.
Gut.
- Danke.
Lucas ist zurzeit im WK.
Aber für heute kriegte er Ausgang.
Rebecca
kommt in Begleitung der Menschen,
die ihr am nächsten stehen:
ihre Schwester und ihr Vater.
So ist gut.
- Geht das so?
Rebecca
perfektioniert noch ihr Outfit,
während Lucas
schon allen Eindruck macht.
Hey, wie geht es?
- Gut.
Es ist vorgeschrieben, dass ich
meine Uniform nur tragen muss,
bis ich am Zielort ankomme.
Aber ich finde, das passt doch
ganz gut zu so einer Diplomfeier.
Ich nehme die Urkunde so entgegen.
Das hätte Rebecca nicht erwartet.
Du bist auch überall.
- Du wirst mich nie los.
Der Sicherheitsbeamte
ist der Türsteher der Disco,
in die Rebecca und ihre Schwester
regelmässig gehen.
Das freut mich. Es ist lange her.
- Ich habe jetzt einen Bachelor.
Ja? Voll gut.
- Yeah.
Ihr findet mich im Gang,
gleich nach dem Eingang.
Gut. Tschau.
Lucas trifft seinen Vater.
Seine Mutter kommt auch gerade.
Schön, seid ihr hier.
Also.
Gehen wir rein?
Sonst hat es keinen Platz mehr.
Bis später. Ich habe euch lieb.
- Bis später.
Ich bin wahnsinnig stolz auf sie
und freue mich total für sie.
Sie hat ihren Weg gefunden.
Für mich ist auch gesorgt.
Für den Notfall und so.
* Lachen *
* Er singt die Musik mit. *
(Frau) Liebe Absolventinnen
und Absolventen.
Die Hälfte Ihrer Studienzeit war
von der Gesundheitskrise geprägt.
Das hat Ihnen viel Anpassungsfähig-
keit und Widerstandskraft abverlangt
und auch
die Studienbedingungen erschwert.
Endlich ist es so weit.
Rebecca Moldoveanu.
* Jubel *
* Zufriedene Musik *
Ah schau,
Lucas Schmidt in voller Montur.
Gratulation.
- Woher kommen Sie?
Von Aigle.
- Gratuliere ganz herzlich.
Merci.
- Herzliche Gratulation.
* Jubel *
* Zufriedene Musik *
Ich bin so stolz auf dich.
- Merci.
Bravo.
Ich bin sehr stolz auf ihn.
Er ist freundlich und sympathisch.
Das sind Charakterzüge,
die die Leute sehr an ihm schätzen.
Das bedeutet mir etwas.
Ich bin sehr stolz.
Wir wünschen uns natürlich, dass ihm
der Beruf viel Freude macht.
Sie hat so viel dafür gearbeitet.
Sie hat so viel Energie
in das Studium investiert.
Sie ist ein grosses Vorbild.
Nächste Woche:
Mit Blaulicht ist Fanny
zu einem kleinen Mädchen unterwegs,
das beunruhigende Symptome hat.
Wie viele Finger sind das?
- Drei.- Drei?
* Weinen *
In Tansania
sind Hélène und ihre Freundinnen
zu einem besonderen Einsatz
unterwegs.
Sie müssen
über Beschneidung sprechen.
Vor Jugendlichen.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022